resguardar los cuerpos de migrantes
irregulares que nadie reclama Este es el
propósito de estos nichos ubicados en un
camposanto del municipio panameño de
pinogana en la provincia del Darién las
bóvedas fueron construidas entre las
ruinas de algunas tumbas en el
cementerio del pueblo una iniciativa que
busca la preservación con dignidad de
los restos de los migrantes el instituto
de Medicina legal Y ciencias forenses de
Panamá y la Cruz Roja local fueron los
abanderados del proyecto
este módulo
forense humanitario
traduzca ese objetivo y es el estar a
disposición de esos restos humanos que
requieren ser preservados con dignidad
sin tener certeza de la cantidad de
personas que mueren en su tránsito por
el peligroso cruce natural los
organismos humanitarios se basan en la
información que entregan los migrantes
que logran sobrevivir historias de una
travesía que muchos prefieren no haber
vivido al comienzo uno no lo ve no lo
pero posteriormente uno identifica que
cada caso lo llamamos caso en realidad
es una persona que tiene una historia
que tiene una familia tiene una madre un
padre además de brindar un reposo digno
a los migrantes en caso de que los
cuerpos sean identificados podrían ser
repatriados y brindarán el cierre de un
ciclo de dolor para los familiares de
las víctimas según cifras del servicio
nacional de migración de Panamá Durante
los dos primeros meses de 2023 al menos
45.700 personas cruzaron la selva del
Darién rumbo al norte en busca de
mejores condiciones de vida